vamos a seguir resolviendo problemas de
porcentajes y en este problema lo voy a
empezar así imagínate que yo tengo 50
pesos en mi billetera
vamos a contar todo esto es muy
importante tengo 50 pesos en mi
billetera y me voy a una tienda
comercial y cuando llego a la tienda me
dan la buena noticia de que el día de
hoy todo está el 25% de descuento todo
está el 25% de descuento del precio del
mercado es decir del precio de venta y
bueno ya que yo tengo estos 50 pesos me
pregunto lo siguiente para no buscar en
vano sería bastante bueno saber cuál es
el mayor precio que puedo pagar es decir
contando que tengo 50 pesos mi billetera
y que todo está al 25% de descuento así
que para resolver este problema lo
primero que voy a hacer es definir a x
precisamente como ese precio sea x igual
al precio más grande que puedo pagar con
estos 50 pesos al precio más grande que
puedo pagar date cuenta que si por
ejemplo algo está en la tienda
departamental a 100 pesos
le aplicamos el descuento entonces el
precio final va a ser de 75 pesos es
decir cualquier producto tiene el 25% de
descuento ahora bien si nos fijamos en
este producto que estoy buscando y este
producto valía x antes del descuento
cuando yo le aplicó el descuento le
vamos a quitar el 25% del precio de este
producto y esto es lo que va a ser
nuestro precio de venta pero x menos el
25% de equis pues si nosotros lo vemos
en su forma decimal nos quedaría como x
menos el punto 25 de x porque recuerda
que el 25% lo podemos escribir en su
forma de small como punto 25 por x x
menos punto 25 x que por cierto x es 1x
y 1 x menos punto 25 x esto es lo mismo
que punto 75 x y bueno este es nuestro
precio de venta y nuestro precio de
venta ya con el descuento es decir que
el día de hoy que esta tienda comercial
está de oferta todo lo vende al 75% o
dicho otra manera al punto 75 de él
original pero bueno yo solamente tengo
50 pesos en mi billetera sería un poco
decepcionante fijarme en cosas que sean
muy caras y no poderlas comprar por lo
tanto yo lo que quiero saber para buscar
mucho más rápido es cuál es el precio
máximo sin descuento en el cual no puedo
fijar para que yo pueda pagar al final
50 pesos eso quiere decir que punto 75 x
sea igual a 1050 pesos que traigo en mi
billetera el 75% del valor original del
producto que voy a comprar tiene que ser
igual a todo lo que traigo que son 50
pesos y entonces de aquí ya podemos
despejar la x si yo he dividido ambos
lados de la ecuación entre puntos 75 me
va a quedar 50 entre punto 75 y ya con
esto obtengo el valor de x es decir el
máximo precio que yo puedo pagar en este
centro comercial así que vamos a hacerlo
punto 75 divide a 50.000 0 y voy a
recorrer el punto de la derecha 2
lugares entonces me va a quedar el punto
justo aquí y entonces realmente 50 entre
punto 75 es lo mismo que 5000 entre 75
está
es mucho más fácil de hacerla no está de
más recordar que primero hay que quitar
el punto decimal y bueno 75 el 50 no
caben pero 75 en 500 si caben 75 por 250
así que cabe como unas 6 veces entonces
vamos a poner aquí 6 veces y vamos a ver
qué es lo que pasa de hecho siete veces
no caben entonces 6 6 por 5 son 30 y
llevamos 3 y después me queda 6 por 7 42
42 3 es 45 y entonces cuando hago la
diferencia de estos dos me queda 50 y
creo que ya estás viendo el patrón
porque aquí otra vez se baja un 0 y
entonces sí borrara todo pues me
quedaría que otra vez cables seis veces
y después seis por 75 450 y después
cuando llegó la resta me queda 50 y así
sucesivamente
es decir que me voy a quedar 6.600 666
el valor de x que estoy buscando es de
66.600 666 y darle 66.666 666 pesos por
lo tanto vamos a redondear los centavos
66 puntos 66
centavos o dicho de otra manera pues
estos números que 66.666 periódico esto
si queremos dar una respuesta
completamente exacta o en su dado caso
pues ya sabemos qué punto 66 66
periódico es lo mismo que dos tercios
entonces nos quedaría 66 enteros dos
tercios pero bueno realmente la
respuesta correcta de 66.67 es un
redondeo a centavos para que lo podamos
pagar en caja es decir que con mil
cincuenta pesos
yo puedo comprar cualquier artículo que
valga 66.67 pesos si le aplicamos el 25
por ciento de descuento en esta tienda
departamental si yo encuentro unos
lentes que valen 66 puntos 65 pesos los
puedo comprar pero si yo encuentro una
gorra que vale 100 pesos pues entonces
no la puedo comprar pero bueno vamos a
hacer otro ejercicio que tenga que ver
igual con dinero así que imagínate que
inicialmente tenemos y en pesos este es
un ejercicio rápido vamos a ver si lo
puedes contestar de una manera muy
rápida tengo 100 pesos y entonces los
meto al banco
por un año y el banco me da un
crecimiento del 25 por ciento perfecto
en un año mi dinero aumenta en un 25%
pero el siguiente año pasa algo muy
trágico en lugar de ganar o de que mi
dinero aumente va a disminuir esta vez
mi dinero se va a encoger en un 25% son
los riesgos de invertir con el dinero a
veces se gana a veces se pierden y bueno
la pregunta es cuánto dinero tengo al
final después de estos dos años y
seguramente lo primero que puedes decir
es oye
esto es demasiado sencillo pues empiezo
con 100 pesos crece un 25% y después se
encoge un 25%
pues acabo con 100 pesos pero hay que
tener mucho cuidado porque no es lo
mismo si dices que es la respuesta
estarías en un error porque fíjate bien
aunque es la misma tasa de interés no es
a la misma cantidad de dinero a la que
se le aplica en un principio vamos a
sacar el 25% de 100 pesos pero en el
segundo año lo que vamos a hacer es
restarle el 25 por ciento
sino a lo que nos salga en el primer año
al resultado de 100 pesos después de que
creció un 25% en el primer año es decir
en el primer año obtenemos 125 pesos el
25 por ciento de 100 pesos es 25 pesos
pero en el segundo año cuando se encoge
nuestro dinero cuando cae todo esto va a
pasar lo siguiente lo que hay que
calcular es el 75 por ciento o punto 75
de 125 pesos muy parecido a lo que vimos
en el ejercicio anterior sin mi dinero
cae 25 por ciento es exactamente lo
mismo que queda no solamente con el 75
por ciento de lo que tenemos de dinero
pero ojo no de los 100 pesos de los 125
pesos que obtuve en el primer año así
que vamos a calcularlo me queda 5 por 5
25 llevamos 25 por 2 10 más 2 son 12
llevamos 15 por 15 más unas son seis
después pongo un 0 7 por 5 35 llevamos 3
7 por 2 14 más 3 son 17 17 14
después llevamos 17 por unas siete más
una son ocho y entonces vamos a sumar
esto 5 7 6 y 4 6 y 7 son 13 llevamos 11
y 8 son 9 93.75 entonces la respuesta de
esto es 93.75 y date cuenta que esto es
mucho menor a lo que empezamos empezamos
con 100 pesos y ahora solamente tenemos
93 puntos 75 pesos disminuyó nuestro
dinero así que aunque la respuesta más
lógica parece ser que son 100 pesos no
es así si el primer año aumenta nuestro
dinero en un 25% y el siguiente año
disminuye a nuestro dinero en un 25 por
ciento realmente estamos perdiendo
dinero bastante interesante este
ejercicio y de hecho también sería
bastante interesante pensar qué es lo
que pasa con acciones y algunas de estas
cosas sin embargo eso lo voy a ver en
otros vídeos ahorita no te quiero meter
mucho en eso pero bueno todo tiene
sentido con esto del dinero cuando sube
y cuando baja o tal vez otra idea
interesante sería preguntarnos cuál es
el porcentaje que tendríamos que
disminuir para llegar a otra
a los 100 pesos pero bueno eso lo
podrías pensar tú en un futuro y lo que
quiero que veas es que ya estás
preparado para cualquier tipo de
problema que tenga que ver con
porcentajes espero que te hayas
divertido así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo adiós